death strandings universe is
meticulously crafted it's so dense
understanding its complexities can be a
burden in and of itself and of course
the game's been out for a few weeks and
you probably still don't know what's
going on but don't worry
ayuk curtain Divina will carry that
weight for you I will untie the knot at
a bilk accord that is the death
straining universe I will make this
artistic vision crystal clear so here we
go in what sounds like a half-hearted
attempt at slam poetry we learned from
Sam Porter bridges portrayed by Norman
Reedus that there were explosions once
there was an explosion once there was an
explosion once there was an explosion
and then came the next explosion
explosions like the big bang or
explosions that created our own fragile
existence or explosions that led to what
is known as the death stranding these
explosions completely reshape the world
into a discombobulated version of itself
it pulled a lot of the American
population into the afterlife created a
new material called Kerr ileum which
formed clouds in the atmosphere that
disrupted global communication systems
crippling the remains of civilization
and forcing survivors into underground
bunkers and the worst part has made rain
even more mobile bomber instead of just
making you wet and depressed rain now
rapidly ages anyone or anything that
touches it this change in climate is
called time fall America is in shambles
however organization bridges is formed
as an effort to rebuild the nation and
in order to do that supplies need to be
transported to the remaining cities to
construct the Strand a line of
communication connecting survivors and
waste stations as a task for you can
execute in this post civilized America
many who've tried either fall victim to
the treacherous threats of this
nightmarish world or become adversaries
themselves referred to as mules delivery
men gone rogue that are addicted to the
thrill of theft and delivery in the
isolated world enter a legendary
delivery boy Sam Porter bridges Sam is
recruited by the President of the United
States of America
Bridget strand who's either old or just
been standing in the rain without an
umbrella who knows
her dying wish is for Sam to rebuild the
crumbled America by delivering the
necessary cargo across the land but
you're probably like we have like cars
and bikes
what about planes why don't they just
have drones delivering the stuff in
which I'm like well Kojima's thought of
everything hasn't he because car LEM in
the atmosphere stops planes and drones
from working so good and besides bomber
rain will just age the crap out of
everything except for raincoats
apparently probably cuz it made out of
plastic and plastic never dies please
recycle this desolate stretch of land
may seem terribly isolating but
thankfully you're not entirely alone you
have a baby in a jar to accompany you on
your long journey across America
delivering sperm and pizzas these babies
are called babies or bridge babies these
playful little cuties come from still
mothers once pregnant women who are in a
catatonic state as a result of BT's will
get into what that's all about
momentarily
BB's perceived the realms of the living
and the dead a line that was blurred as
one of the many innumerable outcomes of
the deaths training event again more on
that later and if the comfort of a
charismatic adorable fetus wasn't enough
there's other justifications for your
sad and seemingly meaningless existence
in a crumpled America being rebuilt by
exaggerated character sure is weirdly
placed in a melodramatic world with
names like die hard men nope I mean die
hard men and dead man nope
dead man anyways it's called the chiral
Network
it burns
the chiral Network is a line of
communication to survivors networks and
other players that connects this
crumpled America together working just
like a social network it's a way of
seeking validation in the form of likes
that you get from creating structures or
leaving messages for lonely porters who
wander through empty landscapes similar
to your own lonely reality where you
seek acceptance by posting pictures of
yourself on Instagram with heartfelt
messages about your amazing and
adventurous life when in actuality
you're alone in a coffee shop buying
drinks that come in Gibraltar glasses
with a little money you have in your
already dwindling bank account just to
feel part of something and maybe just
possibly feel the warmth from another
human being sitting next to you and you
pray for them to sneeze just so it gives
you the excuse to say bless you and that
feels like more of a conversation than
you've had in weeks and I'm talking
about your own sin trivial ways of
seeking validation wasn't our enough
well then love to talk about death baby
let's talk about you and let's talk
about when all this [ __ ] went tits up
the lines between life and death were
blurred paving the way for creatures
called Beach things referred to as BTS
which can cross over into the real world
than the other way around these Beach
things are essentially ghosts and appear
like a black [ __ ] sludge that comes out
of the ground like backed up septic
slurry reminding you that despite how
hard you try to flush it away the amount
of excretion and regret that is your
life will always splash back on your
face get used to the smell thankfully in
this universe you can piss right in the
face of death shucks on four cans of
your favorite energy drink find the
nearest slender man unzip and let it rip
as your warm peepee collides in the face
the Thira manifestation of the afterlife
it'll be overcome by your alpha
delivery-boy dominance and piss right
back off in the sewer systems of the
unknown
that's right BTS are weak to human
bodily fluids further proving that
peeing in public is absolutely fine
naturally with that revelation you're in
better shape to defend yourself as
you're [ __ ] piss and blood can be turned
into grenades to use against these
floating oil smears so the next time
you're checking out of your room eh
because it came home steaming drunk and
ridiculous o clock and find his walls
covered in caca don't judge him maybe he
just ghost busted sweet beautiful beach
made of coal and misery having and you
know Sam Norman freezes bridges you know
why I can't die as a rep tree yet you
know what the rabbit rillette a rep yes
well big spoiler for you buddy well let
me tell you the game okay
well we're out of time and urine so what
do we take away from this trivial
pursuit of trying to understand all this
well maybe some things are best not
being made sense of anyways after all
what is life why are we here and why can
some people juggle and I can't at the
end of the day underneath the artistic
genius and impressive display of
Kojima's friends circle dust training is
a simulator for carrying a mass amount
of crap which likely represents carrying
your own heavy conscience glorified into
a sad lowly mailman game trying to grasp
onto a sad and lonely world
so in short hug your mailman because
this job sucks
leave them cookies for Christmas he'll
appreciate it I did that once
they left me a really nice letter the
biggest mystery in deaths training
however is do you ever see Norman's
penis
well the answer to that question remains
swinging in the wind because every time
you try to turn the camera to sneak a
beak Norman's penis has receipt us
anyway that's the end of part 1 for part
2 I'm gonna teach how to tie your
shoelaces and explain the ending of this
game and if you're not sick of hearing
about this game just yet well then you
should watch the other many many desk
training videos
we have with that said thank you so much
for watching until next time
[Music]
[Music]